here's how the main characters of the
Walking Dead TV show are different from
the comics
we are The Walking Dead both tell the
story of the collapse of society after a
zombie apocalypse there are some major
differences between the two sets of
characters Rick Grimes is the leader of
his group which now resides in
Alexandria and the comic Rick lost his
hand in the first encounter with the
governor the character we said goodbye
to in season four Rick still has his
hand in the TV show despite several
serious injuries the show creators have
said that it would be too difficult to
film
Michonne is a samurai sword wielding
force in both the comics on the show the
TV show nailed her iconic entry to the
series but has taken some liberties with
her current role namely a relationship
with Rick perhaps this is due to the
death of another character remember
Andrea this expert markswoman was a
member of the original group from
Atlanta
she died in season 3 of the TV show in a
shocking twist in the comics she is
still alive in the most recent issue and
is one of the most influential members
of the group she's also in a
relationship with Rick
in contrast is Carol a character who is
Waln outlived her comic-book namesake
yours love Carol in The Walking Dead TV
show because she is a resilient and
capable woman determined to survive
today we're talking about knives however
in the comic series she only makes it to
issue 42 where she allows herself to be
eaten by a walker let's talk about negan
the villain of the moment you're right
Omni we are the Savior's Jeffrey Dean
Morgan drew a lot of inspiration from
the comics Vern Eakins mannerisms and
the show has brought panels from the
comics to life almost exactly however
this actor's portrayal is decidedly less
manic Morgan is revealed in several
interviews that adding more charm makes
Nikken work for television
what if negan's right-hand man is Dwight
while the TV show remains pretty
faithful to his comic book counterpart
viewers get an expanded look at the
characters background before his face
was burnt on the show Dwight also share
some similarities to Daryl a character
who doesn't exist in the comics at all
Daryl was introduced about two years
before Dwight in the comics and many
were quick to notice that both carry a
crossbow Daryl quickly became a breakout
fan favorite on the series your worlds
about to get a whole lot bigger do you
want to see more character comparisons
let us know in the comments below and
subscribe for our latest videos